[Musique]
je m'appelle saisi da rocha cofondatrice
de gênes arrose paris une marque de
joaillerie joyeusement responsable notre
siège et d'un montigny-le-bretonneux
donc dans les yvelines nous
nous avons lancé
ce projet depuis bientôt un an
[Musique]
mon activité consiste à créer des bijoux
uniques intemporel éthique et durable
l'engagement c'est que nos produits
respectent l'environnement et les hommes
par exemple nous travaillons des
diamants et lui en laboratoire
exclusivement il possède exactement les
mêmes propriétés physiques chimiques et
optique qu'un diamant domine notre
partenaire diam concept
fondée par alix geek elle se situe en
france et dans les yvelines plus
précisément aux loges en josas
et qui donc nos fournit principalement
en diamants de couleurs c'est des
couleurs qui correspond à la marque dont
cd couleur cognac champagne
travaillons en slow conception salaire
qu'on ne produit que les juste quantité
puisque on fonctionne avec un système de
précommande pour justement déterminé
c'est juste quantité et ne produire que
le strict nécessaire
[Musique]
en ce moment on lance une campagne de
crowdfunding pour en fait que notre
première collection joy voit le jour
valider nos matières valider nos
produits valider notre concept elle va
nous permettre également de développer
de la r&d pourquoi pas de créer avec nos
partenaires de diamants une couleur jana
rose
[Musique]